it was really a healthy combination of
stunts and then myself doing some of it
as well our first part was showing the
craft getting out of shape as its flying
now we have to see neil eject from it we
have the wire rig that's taking him out
of it we have the lunar lander he was
being manipulated at the same time and
we also have the chair that's ejecting
him and then we have the explosion on
the ground that we're trying to time in
this is he jacked it's like two seconds
three seconds maybe and it hits the
ground
then we go to the landing in the grass
with Ryan himself there's not a lot of
training you can do being dragged across
the field other than just to be dragged
across a field we drug him through the
grass on the lltv he did the landing all
himself being drugged through the grass
and the parachute and I think he liked
it
so we did that I'm gonna keep it to two
Gus the biggest thing of that is on
landing he's got a land okay with his
feet and set himself up to slide
correctly that's his job once he's done
that the rest is kind of autopilot but
the winch program we can help him slide
on the grass of course we police the
area and make sure all the sticks and
stones and all that are gone did you
know that's all him
[Music]
[Music]